foreign
thank you
okay
damn
assalamu alaikum
[Music]
and all the beautiful beautiful brothers
and sisters tuning in how y'all doing
are you a stud
ustad bro Bismillah alhamdulillah
today we are going to be talking about
the problems with sufis now I'm just
playing bro
I love it why one one of my eyes are
bigger than the other bro I'm not gonna
lie I think sleep deprivation does that
yeah and you know I think it's when you
sleep on one side too
um
I've been thinking a lot on my left side
no no I mean this I would be bigger but
then this side is bigger it's weird
bro look at the Noor on your face
look at this
all the noise just lived in it
no comment bro
someone wrote
where's
bro this is what Romney does his stuff
where's Romy
um
wait yo say something let me let me fix
the audio
Rami is
taking care of some of this stuff
let me take care of some stuff basically
me and Anna have been gone for a week
week and a half
romi's been here too much so we
basically told him bro you're not
allowed to come on the stream which is
gonna have to be me yeah he's already
worked all the hours that he had um
available this month so uh we're not
letting him work anymore yeah you got a
one for your brother what you want for
yourself right yeah he's he's this close
to getting fired too
yeah but we're gonna rehire him just you
know
out of a good faith
alhamdulillah
all right so today alhamdulillah if you
guys made it this far into the stream a
couple minutes in Smash that like button
before we go in uh a lot of a lot of
ground to cover today as well you wanna
you wanna go over the itinerary
do you have a hoodie on as well yeah I
have a hoodie on bro I have some okay
okay I was trying Robin I've been I've
been watching too much of these
mashallah these these YouTubers you know
and I noticed one thing bro when you
look at Abu Tamia or any of these
YouTubers they're men but they have a
lot of higher you know what I mean so
it's how it should be bro and the
prophet saws look at the narrations and
and everything on them so at the end of
the day I think I think it's men and
women both oh yeah
underrated area
it's kind of like uh a lot of people
used to ask me
um why do you cover up your hair because
I've been experiencing hair loss for a
while now and for the longest time I
will cover my hair because it was like
I'm more of like an insecurity type
thing right but as time progresses it's
it's like the insecurity is left and now
it's more so I just cover up because
it's like
I don't know it completes it completes
the fit and it's like it's modest at
least I think it's modest you know like
if if you have a thought obviously what
I have on is not really modest but if
you have a thobe and then you have a
kefir like it's it completes the fit and
it's modest it's proper as I yeah but if
you have a soul and you have no uh kefir
goofy or something like this it's not
that there's no light yeah like you have
high yet but it's it's different like in
my opinion it's not the complete fit but
um
someone someone commented what is Aya
what do you think
bro what is it what is the exactly yeah
okay so the beauty of this is bro I
don't want to go full on you know
scholarly mode but the thing with Haya
in Arabic there's multiple meanings in
English there's too many but I like to
go with shyness you know shyness that
little bit of you you you have shyness
obviously from the people but first and
foremost in the eyes of Allah and that
matters a lot bro it's something super
underrated and and people what the hell
is that bro
some of these comments are ridiculous
I'm not even gonna pin them bro okay so
guys today
back to the topic
we are
I'm in my parents house right may Allah
bless them
and
this setup is just in the works so my
internet is kind of bad and because of
that expect if it gets blurry or laggy
it is what it is on Hill he's not in his
permanent residence
Angel doesn't even have a permanent
residence so just just stay tuned guys
bear with us for today uh big
announcement on uh the hell fight did
you and Angel
a Punjabi back from oh did you get on
her Punjabi okay so this is kind of like
a it's like a you know those Arab
dresses that you see they're kind of
like a thobe you know and uh no and your
parents had me wear one yeah my parents
had you wear one when you came over this
man came over I think for Eid a few
months ago
and then uh you pulled up I believe in
that exact top that you're wearing now
and you're you're black
nobody no no it was um
I think it was
a Ramadan yeah no no it was like it was
in June bro
do you remember I took these pictures of
you in that white outfit was that not
the same day
yeah but it was in June like I was in in
Canada in June
Canada in June okay what that makes
sense but actually no it was Eid bro it
was a second Eid
yeah I don't even know what the second
is yeah okay so so basically me you
Romney and Gabriel were chilling it was
the second Eid right
and you're just chopping it up and then
I think Gabriel went home Romney stayed
home and then me and you we just went to
my parents house
and
bro we went to this dessert spot you
remember that
that was terrible bro you you knocked
out after that
listen listen
first
we had food at um didn't we have food at
romy's
uh I'm gonna be honest bro
I believe rami's mom made us something
like she always does mail a bless her
but I don't think we ate anything
I don't know but I do remember like
eating a ton of food at your parents and
then um
we ate too much that and we came back to
your parents house and then your parents
had like a whole more food for us but
bro like hello it's like let's get let's
get into some like real stuff
and this is I feel like we're kind of
like been going off into things that
people would probably be like oh this
isn't a benefit you know people are like
bro why are you guys just having a
conversation with us watching I mean hey
man that was the Neo from day one but
long story short then on her came over
my dad being the the Bengali daddy is
Marshall lamella bless him he's like yo
what you doing bro it's either you gotta
look like it's Eid you know not here
looking like it's eaten quite yet so he
pulled out one of those those thoughts
gave it to on her he put it on mashallah
you were looking fresh and then I think
you rocked that for like the rest of the
day I think we even went to D Spot the
dessert spot with with you wearing the
and me wearing my thought bro
yeah yeah yeah
I'll be honest I'll be honest with you I
didn't hear any of the conversation just
now like the whole thing just cut out
but I I heard the last bit and that is
correct
uh no so to answer the question we want
a little bit of a tangent slightly we
did not bring him back
um
like any thorbs any gifts this time
alhamdulillah last time I did when I
went to Saudi I did alhamdulillah
because I always like to give to my
brothers what I get to myself
um but unfortunately we we didn't the
reason being is
this trip was mainly for my
grandfather's funeral so
he passed away Allah about
I want to say give or take almost two
weeks ago maybe nine ten days ago
and the second we got the news
immediately immediately bro no
hesitation
me and my dad bro we gotta we gotta go
back to Bangladesh bro it's like we're
not we're not missing his janaza funeral
prayer we're not missing his actual
funeral itself like
how sad would that be bro you know what
I mean so we tried to book a flight and
then the same day
the problem was the only flight they had
that day was 7 PM we got the news at 4
pm
so if we wanted to go for the 7 PM
flight we should already left for the
the airport so we left the next morning
went back home and bro let me tell you
this this whole time I was there nothing
else was on my mind bro no no bringing
on her back a gift no no none of the
skiing things bro you know when you go
back home the food is banging bro I
didn't even eat it once nothing bro it
was just I didn't even have an appetite
bro the the main Nia was just to go for
my grandfather's funeral so the thing is
me
he has he has two sounds right my dad
and my uncle so the three of us we we
lowered uh my grandfather's body into
the grave
and bro I kid you not like
you remember how the prophet saws
mentioned like remember often the
destroyer of all pleasures which is
death
and it's it's recommended from what I
know with my limited Layman knowledge to
you know go to the graveyard be reminded
of death keep the remembrance of death
near and it'll basically keep you in
check and I I always knew the wisdom
behind it like logically but I never
felt it spiritually so this was the
first time in my life where as soon as I
went there
and we lowered his body into the grave
his lifeless course
bones I kid you not
it just hit me bro how temporary this
whole life is
how a month ago I didn't even know I
would be here
two weeks ago I didn't even know I would
go to Bangladesh and it kind of just it
reminded me of this quote bro I believe
it's from
uh Fidelity
he basically said that anytime you
basically place too much stress in like
what you're gonna do in this Dunya what
you want to you know do 10 years from
now five years from now where you want
to live what you want to do all this
type of stuff it is
Allah doesn't like that because at the
end of the day we don't have control
over these things anyway so it kind of
just slammed me into that frame of mind
and I really didn't even have time to
process anything so it just and I was in
the Masjid a lot bro like making most of
my Salah in the Masjid too
um which it's very Norm there it's not
as much Norm here most people in the
west pray at home unfortunately
um so all in all this experience was
very humbling for me and it kind of just
put me into like the the most sharp
State of Mind where I have the
remembrance of death near
like I I have never felt how temporary
this Donia is until then
so guys please make Dua for my
grandfather uh that all of his sins are
forgiven that he's granted the highest
levels in Jannah he was a good man he
will always be remembered for
leaving Behind these memories of him
always putting Islam first that's that's
everything that he stood for bro nothing
else
um but anyway with this with the story
time out of the way you got anything
else else to say bro before we do the
the Q a
run it
running boy all right
what I do want to say for all the
brothers that and brothers and sisters
in mind let me correct myself for all
the brothers and sisters that donated to
the uh blind brother for his surgery
I'm actually in contact with him
um if you guys haven't seen any of the
updates all the updates are on my
Instagram so inshallah we'll be able to
put that into the description box in the
comments or something like this if you
want to go check that out
um
for the most part like he's he said
inshallah he's going to be getting his
surgery on Monday so let's just all make
Dua for him I'm in close contact with
him and um
yeah he might actually be able to see
from the surgery though
I love that let's just make Dua for him
and keep a close eye on it and I'll keep
updating everyone with all the
information inshallah
inshallah
all right guys without further Ado let's
let's begin legit questions only no
goofy comments no goofy questions We're
not gonna answer that if you are a
member or it's a super chat you will get
higher priority because it'll show on
the top for us
um Bismillah so first one fired
how much is it to join your program
hit up this this website over here and
we'll talk we'll see on the other side
um okay next question
we do as good as we can
alhamdulillah
for everything man go down bad
luck
Zachary writes your ethnicity was that a
statement my guy
or question
I guess we'll never find though no
what is the best way to introduce Islam
to a non-muslim friend or maybe to guide
them to Islam eventually guys sister
Halima
let me tell you something before I know
it jumps in hidayah
it's not from us
there is no there is no way to guide
anyone to Islam
like hidayah is from Allah Allah you get
what I mean
you could try
that or you could try to inspire people
teaching you to slam bro but ultimately
they had eyes from Allah and there's
many reasons why some people think oh
like if Allah doesn't guide me do I have
a deficiency or flaw or defect or this
person can be guided no bro what if it's
just not the right time how many times
will we hold what to do which is the
right thing by the way but we just
didn't do it because we were like you
know what I don't think that's for me
but then looking back at him you know
what I should have listened to them or
my parents or XYZ right so that that
Consciousness comes from Allah
alhamdulillah by the grace of Allah at
different stages in our life so
sometimes not the best time
other times we gotta trust in Allah's
plan
um but the Dua of guidance I would
recommend you sister halimo to ask your
non-muslim friend better not be
anonymous and ask them
I'm assuming sir uh ask her to basically
make sincere Dua to Allah uh the wall of
guidance is never rejected just pray to
Allah God whatever they they call the
one creator same thing
um just to guide them and inshallah as
Allah azzawajal will guide them and
that's that wrong
I don't know what do you think it's um
I'm not qualified I'm not scholar so
highly highly suggest sister that you go
to with scholar to get the more proper
answer
um the only thing that I would say from
my limited understanding would be just
to be the best example that you can be
you know and always uh
don't be shy with sharing things about
Islam with this person
you know like a lot of times people
might be shy of saying certain things
around non-muslims because it's like
well they don't understand and they they
might feel kind of weird you know you
might feel kind of weird saying Masha
Allah all right alhamdulillah like
around people who who have no idea what
that means and they don't even believe
in religion at all let alone God
so for them like you just you say it
around them and at some point or another
it's going to pique the Curiosity
they're going to ask what does that mean
and then you can it's a it's a teachable
moment so I mean it's again it's my
limited understanding
okay bro I want to bring this up again
um just to add one point that at the end
of the day we're ambassadors of Islam
bro
the non-muslims they don't know what
Halal and Haram is they don't know about
Islam they don't know about the Quran
they don't know about the Hadith They
Don't Know About The Messengers a lot of
them
um they don't know about the
traits of Allah right so at the end of
the day
for us we must understand that every
time we step foot out of the house and
even at times in the house we are
representing Islam so we can't be moving
a certain way where we're pushing other
people away from Islam we can't be
overwhelming them we can't be too harsh
on them we can't be too Cutthroat it's
important to have emotional intelligence
a lot of times people don't necessarily
need what you think they need they need
what they need but we talk to them as if
we're talking to ourselves so being in a
in a cognizant state of that I think
will be very conducive a lot of the
problems in the dawa which we're going
to make a video about very soon in each
other live stream when Romney's back in
a few days
is that we're not representing Islam the
way the the prophet messenger
of Allah the the sahaba
all these these beautiful ambassadors of
Islam represented Islam we're doing it
in a way where there's a lot of ego
involved you know what I mean and I'm
not going to name any YouTubers or
anything like that
um but it is something that inshallah we
got to keep in mind
how do you guys take care of your face
water
the something that I learned before I
became Muslim was that all the products
that you use on your face like
the acne creams the uh cleansers the
scrubs the moisturizers it's the Soaps
but it's all fake man just use water
your body would take care of yourself
and eat proper food exercise spend a
good amount of time Outdoors get sun
that's it simple that's it boys
speed us I'm assuming is is music really
hard on so again we're not a scholar
we're not a scholar what the hell does
that even mean we are not Scholars we
are not qualified to give a tawa to give
rulings you know
um but from our limited limited one more
time limited understanding
um musical instruments are indeed
clear-cut Haram reason being is there's
there's an authentic narration where the
Prophet saw mentions that there will be
people of my ummah that will come and
they will basically make so and so
things they will try to make these
things permissible
you can't make anything or try to make
something permissible if it's already
permissible that would make no sense
so the only
extrapolation from this clearly from
majority of scholarly consensus is that
it's only things that are Haram that
obviously one can make Allah will try to
make hello or permissible oh because of
that
the list of things that you included
included musical instruments
um I think there were many other things
too like wearing silk and gold for men
stuff like that
um so yeah it's clearly impermissible
now there's a difference in opinion and
if in the sheets or vocals are
permissible or not
um I would recommend anyone that anytime
you're stuck in between
Halal Haram you know what I mean like
where something's not clear-cut
um I think this was
I believe I'm not 100 on it but he was
saying anytime you're basically in a
bridge between Halal and Haram where
something is neither explicitly
mentioned to be Haram and some Scholars
say it's not Haram but then it's also
it's it's unbefitting you don't know if
it's mokro or not
then I read this this one text again
don't take my word for do your own
research that if you do it and there's
valid opinions that it's not necessarily
Haram then there's no sin but then if
you don't do it then you basically are
rewarded and it actually purifies your
your heart as well so at the end of the
day if you're ever caught in between
best bet if you have the fortitude to do
it just avoid it at all costs
is the Hadith
that's uh mentioning the whole things
about the instruments
um being forbidden is that is that here
yeah so I believe it is and I'm just
going to double check because if it was
not right
um if it was not authentic then there
would not be any use of this Hadith
today it would hold no Jewish credential
weight let alone eat your Scholars using
this Hadith they would not do this bro
if it was not what's the thing so let me
just pull that on the wrong
um but while I pull that up I will let
you answer the next question
figure out the main thing that you want
to focus on
and uh just start start learning what
you have to learn you'll never have 100
of knowledge on these things so just
start with uh The Limited knowledge that
you have
don't expect Perfection and um
I feel like success rate is much higher
in numbers
so if you have like a person that you're
doing the podcast with or several people
that you're doing the podcast with makes
it very easy to stay on top of it you
know because at some point you're not
going to feel like doing the podcast but
then the other people that are involved
are going to keep you on track so
it's a it's a very good
way of ensuring that the things actually
get done
because um had it been had it been just
me doing the podcast
probably wouldn't be here I'd have been
just fired who knows but I'm feeling
also probably wouldn't be there and run
me as well also like man may Allah bless
him he's a Powerhouse in terms of his
knowledge
but it's it's the same thing it's like
we're human we're subject to emotions
and all this stuff and
podcast like bro like or assist is this
a sister bro it's a brother Elias
brother my bad forgive me bro so it's
man it's it's work it's work bro I'm not
gonna lie to you and like you're trying
to do the podcast I'm guessing on top of
everything else this is not the only
thing you're trying to do in your life
at the moment so it's it's definitely
work my guy
so do consider getting like multiple
people on to this podcast with you
we didn't know how much work it was
wrong until we started
all right so this is in sahih bukhari
five five nine zero uh it says the the
prophet saws said from among my
followers there will be some people who
will consider illegal intimacy like out
of wedlock and all that
um the wearing of silk
for men
the drinking of alcoholic drinks
and the use of musical instruments as
lawful
there will be people that try to
consider them lawful let's just think
about that
and there will be some people who will
stay near the side of a mountain and in
the evening their Shepherd will come to
them with their sheep and ask them for
something but they will say to him
return to us tomorrow
Allah will destroy during the night and
we'll let the mountain fall on them and
he will transform the rest of them into
monkeys and pigs and they will remain so
till the day of Resurrection subhanallah
so it's pretty clear and also understand
too
um I believe it was Adam alaihissalam
who when he had his his progeny his
lineage they were basically uh
segregated there was no mixing and any
of that between the two and I believe
shaytan use musical instruments to
basically get them to commit heinous
things in the eyes of Allah so it's it's
very clear like also another thing to
honor personally you know coming from a
non-muslim background right not to air
your sins or anything like that but it's
very normal as a non-muslim you you
probably didn't know about Islam and
that music is musical instrument you
know right
so I'm sure there was a little bit of a
shift when he came into Islam so do you
want to talk about things you've noticed
because it's it's oftentimes not until
that we leave something along that that
we can actually notice the the impact
that it had on us
um
so it's going to be your subjective
but I'm sure if people were to apply it
to them as they probably noticed these
things as well
um
so music in and of itself
can control someone based on the
frequency that it's uh playing at
you know and then if you if you ever
if she ever tested it if you listen to a
sad song you're probably gonna end up
feeling sad
and how is this is because the frequency
it almost like takes down this barrier
and when when it takes on this barrier
like you know
I'm not saying the physical movement I'm
saying like a mental barrier it takes
down this barrier and then it's like
everything that's in the song is being
just like
uh planted into your brain like
programmed into you to where it's
affecting you on a subconscious level
maybe consciously you're not really
thinking about it much
but on a subconscious level it's
affecting you how can you know this is
you ever had those moments where your
body is like moving to the beat of a
sewing you just kind of like Bob into it
you're like damn this be smacks no this
beat doesn't smell it's actually beating
the life out of you right now it's
programming some disgusting stuff into
into your psyche and bro I realized this
before it's like so I remember I was
stopping like listening to music but I
would still listen to
um like instrumentals or like very I
guess like different types of music
where it doesn't have any words but it's
more like
like Focus type music and stuff like
this but it's still music and like it
still has an effect on me
and and I noticed this when I did a
dopamine detox
or it's like if I try to focus on
something without let's say
you know who Han Zimmerman is right
no yes you do bro the dude who did like
the interstellar and um Inception
soundtrack and all that
I actually I think I know the soundtrack
but I actually don't know the guy but I
got you guys he's made like these are
like
soundtracks with no music it was no like
there's no vocals but it's it's probably
if you were you know I jumped down and
listened to this stuff and it's it's
very nice for like just studying and
getting very focused in on something
and I remember I would I would test it
out I would do what I had to do without
this soundtrack and then I would do what
I had to do with this soundtrack and the
the mere fact that the soundtrack had an
effect on my ability to focus and I'd
say my emotional state and my mental
state I'm just like yo like that's crazy
even this like this classical soundtrack
instruments only had an effect on like
my psychological emotional and mental
state is is beyond me bro Beyond me so
again like now that you have these
Hadith where it's sahih it's like you
have to you have to question these
things you have to be very very
observant and you gotta see who's like
who's actually saying things about music
being permissible and stuff like that
it's usually it's usually sufis right
people who go into the Sufi sect and I
think some shias and stuff like this
but it's like well if you start looking
into that you kind of see where things
get a little hazy that's all I'm going
to say that it's a little hazy
you know
I agree with you bro my experience with
a lot of these things that I left back
in jahelia was the same thing very
similar
um and it wasn't until
I'm not even gonna say months bro
sometimes Years bro looking back and
just realizing like how much dead weight
I left back you know what I mean
hayat asks where is Rami so again
mentioned in the beginning of the stream
brother Romi is absent today he already
maxed out his billable hours bro he's on
probation now I don't know if he's gonna
be back I'm just fine
um I believe inshallah this Wednesday
it's only going to be me and Nami uh for
the Wednesday stream this week uh coming
up because it's too late for Anjo where
he's at unless you want to you want to
be up a bad night bro by all means be my
guest uh but then this coming Saturday
in exactly a week it's going to be the
28th inshallah we are bringing on Sony
Faz and his mom for part two inshallah
see what it do
Sam asks
salaam uh for the Super Chat first uh
Salam made a very hard decision to
become a physician assistant but my
Muslim parents do not agree because I am
not a full doctor
I know they want the best but how do I
handle them shouting at me for my choice
sheesh
is this is is this a brother is this a
sister uh so Sam is a is a very
androgynous name
you know what androgynous means yeah
that's why I ask so I think I think in
many countries bro including the states
It's actually an offense to assume
someone's gender bull
so I don't care bro yeah bro I don't
even care bro let's let's assume listen
statistically speaking there's more men
uh with the name Sam than women so let's
just say brother bro I think it's the
world I think it's a sister bro I think
it's about his assistant come on bro
it's a smiley face
what's a smiley face she put Salam with
a little smiley face what if she could
do it's just a little fruity bro like
who are you to assume come on
um
if it's a sister please please
um let us know because that's gonna
literally give all the basis of like
what the answer is gonna be if not I
can't really answer the question yet ah
bro so I made a very hard decision to
become a physician assistant okay so
let's let's unpack this first you made
you made a hard decision to become a PA
which is fine from the love because it's
not only is it a hard decision
the consequences of the decision are
harder as well because to continue on
that path it's going to take a lot of
forbearance a lot of skill discipline
hours energy money so may Allah bless
you to be successful in that if it's
truly meant for you
um I mean
but then you said my Muslim parents do
not agree to get a full doctor so it's
kind of like any time I see this a lot
in like Desi Asian communities where
it's like someone wants to be a nurse
they're like okay why don't you just
become a doctor someone wants to be this
so why don't you become that
and I'm going to give some advice from
myself that when it comes to a lot of
these cultures
they've been indoctrinated by Western
colonialist
propaganda which will basically promote
this capitalistic worldview and and
establish the most important precedence
in Dunya and only Dunya all these people
will just Chase Dona they're gonna want
this degree this qualification this much
money
and I'm not saying these are bad
Pursuits of course they help us navigate
this this life to help us make money
stay away from Haram right so no one's
denying that but what I'm saying is
these things per se
won't matter much in the eyes of Allah
because it's already clear what things
pleases Allah and what things don't
these things could be a bonus if you're
already a good Muslim if you're on on
point as a Muslim you're doing your best
you're striving to please Allah right
but I think these things are very
secondary and some people just won't get
it so take this advice how you will may
Allah bless everyone's parents for being
super super you know motivational uh
pushing us to you know get all these
these Badges and Stripes it's fine but I
really don't think you should pay any
mind number one if they're they're
shouting it yeah I get it but at the end
of the day see where they're coming from
they're not coming from a place of hate
they're also understand most likely
immigrant parents and if they're
immigrant parents they've been kind of
pigeonholed into this whole fight or
flight kind of mentality you know they
came here probably left all their
comfort back home they came here they
were probably lower class didn't have
much money didn't have much ground to
stand on and they're they're they're in
fear bro they've seen kind of the other
side of of the the whole fake American
dream that they propagate you know
they've seen the other side they've seen
the reality and because they they're
kind of out here trying to protect you
from going through similar things and
they don't necessarily need you to be a
doctor but they they see being a doctor
as a token of security stability success
and they want you to be secure no matter
what that's the most important thing so
if you can show them that okay being a
you know PA I'm still going to be secure
being a PM so they're gonna make a lot
of money there's still a lot of buttock
in it still a lot of hair it's not a
Haram job
um and you're saving lives you're
helping people so if you explain it to
them that way alhamdulillah if they're
with it they're with it if they're not
I don't want to go there but there's a
lot of fatawa
um majority of Scholars unanimously
um you know have a consensus that your
parents although we have to obey them we
have to respect them for sure but when
it comes to what you want to do for a
career
there's no there's it's not Haram to
basically do what you want to do instead
of following their desires for you
um but I do want to want you to
understand just because Haram doesn't
mean we got to be you know sussed about
it we got to be mean about it we should
still sit them down try to get them to
understand even and it's never a
one-time thing to understand this it's
probably going to be a multiple time
conversation
um but if you can do that inshallah
it'll be very beneficial for you
so
if it's a sister
and then um
what if I had said stands true
nothing wrong with being a physician
assistant especially if again you're a
sister and a brother is going to you
know you're going to get married to a
brother and he's going to provide
because at some point you're gonna let
it go so it's like why spend so much
time
working for this like high title
position and then you get married and
then you have to let it go at some point
whereas you can work for I mean you
could study for a brief period of time
get this decent title position that'll
give you good good money
but you don't really have to worry too
much when it's time to let that go and
actually have kids and have a family and
all that now it's a brother who's asking
this question
I told you bro
hold you okay
bro I'm all right man forgive me forgive
me but this sucks and because I'm not
about to be real harsh with you man uh
the question I have for you now is why
do you want to be a physician's
assistant
you know like if if you had something
else you want to do that's completely
understandable but
why would you choose a lesser position
when at some point you will have to
provide for your family
you will have to provide for a wife like
let's just put this into consideration
let's put yourself in the future here uh
you're about to get any killer you're
about to get married
okay do you think that the money that's
going to come in from a physician
assistant and please don't let me don't
don't make this uh like if I'm beating
you down I don't want to sound like I'm
beating you down I'm just trying to like
bring the facts here as Horses in my
song do you really think the money from
a physician assistant is going to give
you everything you need for you your
wife and then now let's say you're
having a kid now let's see you're having
two three four five five kids right we
don't know how much you're gonna have
and it's all in the color of Allah but
it's not going to be enough money you're
going to struggle and bro like
you can't progress like you're not going
to be able to get to the point where you
can start making even more money as a
physician's assistant I mean you might
to a certain extent but not really that
much so it's like if again I gotta ask
like
at that point like are you really gonna
make enough money and if if you want to
do something different now I completely
understand that you want to make a
business I'm an entrepreneurship let me
let me finish but let me finish bro
that's um please make bankroll
PA's name
Physicians that's all I have to stop you
bro uh maybe it's it's a lot a little
bit of ignorance on on the career
because a lot of a lot of these things
we don't know how much money they make
but they make a lot of money bro the
Physicians assistants I've heard of some
making 150 a 200k a year bro trust me oh
forgive me bro forgive me I didn't know
this my bad okay that's ignorance so
much oh yeah
yeah yeah my bad forgive me forgive me
no no no no no no no it's definitely
that's my my bad but um what I'm saying
still Rings true like aside from the
money now like do you feel like that's
something that you're going to be
content with
you know because how much time does it
take to actually become a physician's
assistant
it takes from what I what I remember
I think it's about three to four years
three to four years yeah
and you're pretty much qualified just as
much as a normal physician
okay but then the question is like
would you would you be happy with that
would you be paying time with that
you know because and not everyone's the
same year so that's why I got to bring
the question up so again forgive me for
the ignorance and forgive me for being a
little harsh in the other thing I was
thinking of something else here I was
thinking that you weren't going to be
making as much money
but um it's a genuine question that you
should ask yourself like are you
actually going to be cool with that
several years down the line
if I had an auto looking a little more
chatty chatty
Chad Chad am I Giga Chad
Chad
I'm good is from Allah
right how do you guys give that out to
someone who rejects books
okay
uh they write they ask how do you give
dawah to someone who rejects books
yeah again I think it's more so just
here
your actions the example all that stuff
I appreciate that man may Allah bless
you and I'll uh make it the way you see
it I mean
sister how all right do we have your
permission to use your videos and add
subtitles in other languages for
non-english speaking brothers and
sisters I'm sister from Friends of
course
uh just make sure to uh write that it's
the three Muslims try to you know link
it back to a channel as much as possible
and may Allah allow you to get immense
good deeds in Baraka from trying to
propagate our movement into multilingual
Avenues I mean
Medina
I'm a 13 year old boy from Belgium and I
always watch your videos the Lord bless
you
look like a cat World wow
yeah yeah again again bro my bad damn
man forgive me brother it's completely I
was thinking about some of those
it's all good bro
uh let's see
what time is it I can't see the time
oh wait no it's not it's not 855 it's
12. yeah
damn now you all know it's time zone
I mean if they really want to like
Google it I mean bro like I have videos
on Instagram where I was I was like
saying oh yeah I mean no that's that's
what's up bro no no precise location
though you know yeah just general
optimistic living Channel asked what are
y'all grateful for everything
alhamdulillah
what is your your perspective on it as
someone who used to be a little bit more
into me
uh again we're not Scholars man we can't
give you a direct ruling
um for me personally I'm I'm under the
understanding that for training purposes
hey by all means as long as you're not
like
trying to really kill the other person
hurt the other person
don't depend on what we say for uh your
action
alhamdulillah
it's clean advice bro
he's uh he's thinking some stuff man
inshallah he'll be done soon see bro I'm
telling you people already knew man
turkey is is beautiful alhamdulillah
what's you what you what you pick up on
so far about turkey you want to talk
about that
I mean I feel like I'm in kind of the um
you know like when you just visit a
place and it's like
it's like then that honeymoon stage
right
I felt like I was in that honeymoon
stage
and I was like hmm
I wonder if this would be a decent area
to
to do Hijra
so I pray this is harder and I'm not
gonna say I have any signs or anything
but the moment I'm pretty Sahara it's
like Allah immediately started to reveal
like all the the bad parts about turkey
the bad things about turkey so
um I'm just kind of seeing that it's not
perfect nothing in this world is perfect
it's done yet obviously but
Istanbul was beautiful I'll tell you
that much especially when you go into
the uh
what would you call it that little body
of water like would you call it a harbor
would you call it a
more like a creek
into the creek but it's the ocean though
is the body of water the the boss River
the one you're talking about
foreign
it's beautiful when you go on those
boats and you just look up on the Hills
you see like the mountainsides and you
see all the different buildings and you
see the big masjids bro beautiful big
masjids all over like I'm talking about
the moment you look it's like one two
three four five six seven bro and
they're all huge masjids beautiful
like the bloom of Hagia Sophia these I
think these are like the biggest biggest
but like all the other ones aren't that
much smaller to be honest they're all
very comparable in size and beauty
when you when you when you went to
Turkey did you have the Adana kebab
the donut Adana
what is this that's like the Bro one of
the main kebabs bro banging I had that
everywhere bro it's like lamb and it's
like red meat it's so good bro
I don't know about all the food's
amazing but recently I tried some of uh
it's like mussels and they made them in
like rice like they cook up rice and
they smash it into the mussels it's
almost like sushi but it's oh my God it
was so much better than sushi
bro you got me you got me excited now
yeah
um
from time to time I try to remind myself
just to keep the position the tongue
position because
um if not then our tongue tends to be
like all over the place instead of like
on the roof of our mouth
you like that fire
bro I don't know what the hell you Mew
is mewing mewing
they're all do your Mew
oh what is what is mewing I thought they
were talking about the Pokemon Bro
no but that was um
it was a very rare Pokemon by the way it
was uh it was a flying cow or something
like that
flying alien cat
no but mewing is a a specific practice
to restore your facial structure
hmm
you do it viewing and Consciousness I
mean
I want to say no but
you're focusing in on something so
perhaps you know perhaps and Allah bless
you brother
and you as well
I think that was the system but oh
bro take that back nah but if it's a
brother then I mean
um okay
AOG asked would you do a podcast with
you and inshallah we love them why not
asked what are the biggest lessons
you've learned since starting YouTube
with great power comes great
responsibility that would be for me what
about you
damn
I think the biggest lesson that I
learned since being on YouTube
especially in the PBM
is uh just how ignorant I am
and they're like well ignorant to an
extent and we try to make excuses and
say we're studying and we're learning
and all this stuff
but like when you actually have to speak
on these topics and
it just kind of forces you to see the
reality of things and the reality is
like
I'm very ignorant and I think I'll
probably be very ignorant to the day I
die
alhamdulillah may Allah increased me in
knowledge but it's just it's so much
I mean bro I mean
and trust me bro at the end of the day
there's I believe this is this is a
Hadith where it basically mentions that
if you take the steps for the sake of
Allah to seek knowledge Allah will
basically just push you with the men's
Baraka definitely butchering it but just
make life easy for you in the Affairs in
this this life and the next inshallah
alhamdulillah
Anonymous writes you guys should get
hijab on the podcast been there done
that just search up the three Muslims
Muhammad hijab or Muhammad hijab the
three Muslim something like that from a
while ago
Frost for us would y'all still have a
convoy with young Don so many of you
that aren't aware of what this person is
talking about we had a little bit of
this I I want to say heated bro and I
know y'all see the clickbait sometimes
but this just generally was heated bro
lines were crossed disrespect was made
towards Islam towards Allah towards the
prophet saws
and I'm gonna say just from the goodness
of my heart they were made from his end
of ignorance
and if you all haven't seen any of the
videos just search up the three Muslims
you have done watch some of them and it
was this whole like Arc you know when
you watch an anime bro there's like one
Arc it was literally like an arc like a
chapter and looking back at it I still
want him Insha'Allah to be guided to
Islam of course I still want that
um so from that point of view would
y'all still have a convoy with yeah I'm
gonna speak for myself and then Allah
carry over but when you look at people
in Makkah when you look at history when
the prophet sallam was trying to
basically convey Revelation give dawah
the amount of heat the amount of
animosity the amount of opposition he
got
bro not just verbal physical
to the point where they were throwing
stones and rocks at him
stuck for Allah he literally passed off
from that type of stuff and it was it
was very hard it was not an easy Journey
nonetheless
and even at that time lead you look at
so-called Once Upon a Time people knows
of Islam they were opposing Islam they
were even offering Muslims right they
were never shot off from
October from seeking forgiveness and
repenting to Allah and they were never
shut off from accepting Islam
so from that point of view Taliban will
lead the sword of Allah we all know that
all the beautiful people that yes sure
once upon a time they were ignorant they
were programmed but then they came into
Islam I think because of that
I mean it's it's I'm not gonna be close
I'm not gonna be a gatekeeper from
foreign
spewing things out of hatred and doing
things out of context
um bringing on apost first stream and
just spewing nonsense bro for hours the
leading streams deleting comments
changing the truth if he can acknowledge
even announce that maybe
but if it just continues the way things
stand out probably not
yeah I agree
fair enough
I hear some of these
problem listen man we are Muslims
oh bro listen this scam is fans too
don't even get me started on that bro
just just type Young on scam or
something like that made a video on the
this was I forgot about that but it just
goes to show how much like I don't hold
these things too hard but it's it's so
problematic bro it's about a lot
um some we're gonna assume it's a
brother again bro listen to me
statistically speaking as a brother
right what is your advice for being all
around Haram or holding on to Halal
I mean
just keep moving in the direction of the
Halal bro Allah knows
what's in your heart and Allah says in
the Quran that he he will never punish a
Slave
so long as they are asking for
forgiveness
as they're repenting so just keep asking
for forgiveness from Allah
keep moving in that direction
and uh just know Allah sees everything
inshallah
wolf
asks about our thoughts on gaming
because he is against it
we had uh this brother on here the uh
productivity athlete according to me I
didn't I didn't make that stream nor did
I watch it later but I knew bro if
anyone talked about it would be him
yeah he talked about gaming uh it could
be a beneficial thing for some people
who um needs some kind of leisure
activity Oh I thought he was going to
talk about reaction time or something
like that
yeah
um reaction time is something to
consider especially for games like
um Call of Duty and stuff like this but
you got to think like do you really need
the reaction time for whatever it is
that you experiencing in your life
the answer to that will probably give
you the answer and then you gotta ask
yourself are you willing to sacrifice x
amount of time every single day or
whenever it is that you play these games
to do this thing for this quote-unquote
benefit from reaction time
um
I don't know I feel like it can be a
benefit to some people but for most it's
probably not going to be a benefit you
know for most it's like you could
probably use your time better
but again like I said
could be a benefit for some
I'm personally would struggle for a
while and I still do because I'm I'm
human bro just like y'all
um to feel that spiritual connection
sometimes sometimes it's logical
cerebral which is fine you know because
we we have rational based conviction in
Islam there's no Blind Faith here but
when it comes to ibada sometimes just
mechanically going through all the
you know the obligations that we hold in
Islam
can be
burning us out more than we'd like to
admit and having that intrinsic
motivation or inspiration to continue
for the sake of Allah makes it easier
um so definitely it is important to
strengthen your spiritual connection so
just mechanically going through all
these different obligations now
one thing that helped me personally I
mentioned the stream the last week I
went to the Masjid
pretty much like I think three or four
of the the daily prayers every single
day for the week that I was back home
and bro I kid you not my Iman was at
Next Level my spirituality my connection
to Allah is next level subhanallah bro
and it was I'm pretty sure it was just
due with that because just constantly
being there in that environment I
realize now why it's better for us at
least especially men to go to the majors
every day for our Salah
would do
I was going to say that and I was just
gonna say
to spend this time on electronics
and uh you'll see for yourself
I'm not even gonna say anything it's
really see for yourself
inshallah
brother Bilal Mela bless you for the
soundtrack for always supporting our
Channel bro
I'm gonna meet up some um
uh Anonymous rights you know there's a
Hadith there will come a time when
holding onto your religion will be like
holding on to a hot cold or burning coal
yeah this is this is facts and don't
think that time is far from now if
already here
stick us oh no have you seen a Dream
from Allah or a dream that came true
oh damn it bro
yeah I I haven't had dreams subhanova
where they come true it's um it's crazy
I wouldn't I don't know David from Allah
maybe some of them for sure but I've
seen them I come through and
so it's it's crazy for sure
are you strategizing the child's growth
hell no we used to put a lot of time
into that now we're just posting
whatever and letting Allah take over and
alhamdulillah it's less work with more
Roi whereas before we were trying to do
all these things and planning and doing
the most bro it's kind of cringe looking
back at it no remember those edits bro
those those goofy ass edits bro
yeah
a money sister Miller bless you for
becoming a member
update on the Discord I wouldn't know
that's wait till around me comes back
let's see
okay what do you think about this
okay you could just call me Rami bro I
was gonna say it wrong like my like my
dad bro mixing up me and my little
brothers you know why because I'm
literally about a message on me right
now
um because apparently there was a
brother that wanted to take uh shahada
today
um so I'm just trying to see if we can
do that
so do you want to answer that wrong I
mean my friend is taking
masha'allah do you have any tips for him
um keep Simple read the Quran and learn
how to do the prayer don't try to do all
this extra stuff
um what stuff should it take to start a
Praying
I can't say this is like a lot
or you know something that's even
promoted but I started with just
uh having the video playing and
following along to what the guy was
saying in the prayer
until I could actually like
um kind of do it myself and then when I
could do it myself I started with only
one prayer every single day and then
after about a week of doing that I
bumped it up to two
um then once I got the two I was just
like you know what colors let me just do
all of them and then from there I've
been doing operators ever since I'm
doing that so again I can't say I can't
say it's promoted or recommended but uh
just I don't know just do a little
expense and this bro this is a very
giant it's a very ignorant opinion I'm
I'm still very you know trying to learn
everything I'm not a scholar at all but
again keep it simple keep it simple and
just keep making steps to
uh learning how to pray getting closer
to Allah and reading the Quran and all
that stuff and inshallah will make it
easy for you
insha Allah
oh the shahada brothers coming let's go
uh do you want to catch this
yeah yeah we can the only thing I can
say from here is uh Allah Knows Best Man
I have no no knowledge over this
um we got some Scholars but
I have no knowledge over this drone
alhamdulillah
all right let me let me comment this
right now
because
I want this to be on the screen when the
brother comes take the shadow inshallah
foreign
heavy
how did you get to the highest level in
Jannah
yeah follow the Quran and the Sunnah boy
that's it
it's simple
if you can follow that to a T
are you on the right track
hmm
inshallah
I wouldn't know about this
I don't know
all right let me bring this up
oh
because I want I want him to read it you
know we're visual
I don't want no uh no errors
inshallah
let's see
the correct let's see
hold up bro there we go
let me just double check this at Shadow
online
you store this
how are you doing today my love
foreign
the question is how are you doing today
Messi or Ronaldo I don't really watch
soccer
bro am I the only guy that doesn't watch
sports I find it so like such a waste of
energy
man I'll tell you what I've always been
the guy that's um I'd rather play the
sports than watch
hmm okay
bro Sam's going in just to clarify on
hell I'm a 19 I'm a 19 man oh bro
there's 19 men bro in this one account
it's not even one guy
I'm just playing I'm giving you a hard
time bro you guys know what I have the
type of properly also do any of you have
any workout routines or website I can
follow melon bless everyone uh YouTube
Bro underrated definitely inshallah yeah
and again bro forgive me man I thought
you were I thought you were sister
may Allah bless you in in whatever
Pursuit you end up taking bro I mean
foreign
how's it going man bro I'm good I'm good
I'm ready bro Habibi this is this is the
moment you've been waiting for
um listen unlike unlike brother Rami
everyone uh if you made it this far
smash the like button spam the comments
with shahada time uh and Ethan bro
before we go right into it I want to
know a little bit about your journey
thus far right so of course we're gonna
do the shahada but please let us know
bro anything and everything you want to
share about what made you get to this
point right now
yeah um basically I was raised as an
atheist
um in fact I'd actually see my family
are more antitheists the kind of like
mocked religion my whole life
um but myself I was always more agnostic
but
I suppose the last
six months or so I started watching like
debates between Muslims Christians
atheists Jews every single time the
Muslim would win I'd never saw a Muslim
lose any debate ever
um so I suppose
that's that's what led me here
personally
I mean
I I dealt with addiction for many years
um and the only thing that helped me
come out with that was my relationship
with God
I'm at a point in my life now where
I need to take it to the next step I
think
Angela okay cool bro so we're just gonna
go over a little bit about some of the
beliefs that you required to be a Muslim
yes um so these we have the five floors
of Islam these are basically the five
things that are required from you as a
Muslim
and then there's the six pillars of his
Iman right the six pillars of Iman or
Iman Loosely translated to Faith right
but there's there's so many other ways
to describe it but just convict the lack
of what a word
um these are things that are basically
requisite for you to be Muslim so
they're not really responsibilities or
things you have to do like the five
pillars of Islam but these are more so
things that we need to just see where
your approach it's very simple questions
um if you don't mind so we'll go over
those all right any questions yeah sure
and I'll go ahead go ahead
so the first question is do you believe
in Allah that there's there's a Creator
there's God and God is one 100 100
perfect do you believe in the Angels the
angels that Allah sends to give
Revelation I do yes and then the third
thing is the Revelation that I just
mentioned the Revelation
um or scripture you know the Quran and
the previous scriptures that God has
sent
yes perfect do you believe them I've got
to go on here bro that's perfect and do
you believe in the messages Messengers
or prophets of God that Allah sends
Revelation to to then relay to mankind
absolutely perfect do you believe in the
day of judgment that one day we're going
to be held into account for all of our
Good Deeds
um and everything like that yes perfect
do you believe in Divine decree or
predestination which we call the color
of Allah so that Allah is all-knowing
and basically has a Divine decree laid
out for us yes perfect bro that's it I
think I think you're qualified and I
think you you have that understanding
alhamdulillah now with regards to the
five pillars of Islam is basically going
to be you know the shahada which is
necessary for you to become a Muslim
um that's the first thing the second one
is prayer yeah your five daily prayers
we'll talk about all that bro we'll
create like a group chat with me you
angel and Rami uh we'll send you some
resources too and it's a step-by-step
thing but the child is the most
important
um the third and fourth are you know
fasting in the month of Ramadan if
you're able to uh no medical conditions
or anything like that and then the zakat
which is the 2.5 percent
of our unused excessive wealth that just
sits in your possession that we have to
give to the needy and then the fifth one
is Hajj which is the pilgrimage uh that
we make to the Kaaba in Saudi Arabia at
least once in your life if you are able
to does that make sense yeah yeah so
that's it how are you feeling great
alhamdulillah okay sounds good bro so
let me pull this up right now in Arabi
and then I will basically read out and
you can just repeat after me sound good
yep hold on okay
[Music]
I bear witness I bear witness that there
is none that there is none worthy of
worship worthy of worship except Allah
except Allah and I bear witness and I
bear witness the prophet Muhammad the
prophet Muhammad is the final messenger
and servant of God is the final
messenger and servant of God
you're not Muslim thank you I appreciate
that guys of course bro
I feel like a way it's been lifted off
my shoulders I've been waiting a while
to do this to be honest really yeah
oh man oh no bro
bro
it's just a real experienced man you're
probably gonna feel that for like a good
month yeah
more than that definitely
um bro do you have any questions or
anything like that because I'm sure you
know now that you became Muslim
obviously alhamdulillah we have this
little bit of a spiritual High which is
fine
um but I'm sure if you have any
questions bro we'd love to you know go
through some of these things
yeah I guess
um what's the next step from here okay
so the next step that I recommend is
going to be to learn how to pray no
prayer or Salah Loosely is as again we
know it's Loosely translated to prayer
um but worship would be a better term
because understanding that the main Neo
or intention of us doing SLA is yeah we
can make Dua which is asking Allah and
no one said you can't do it but it
should be irrespectable we should be we
should be prostrating and worshiping
Allah by virtue of Allah not necessarily
because of what we want to get out of it
although we will get tremendous benefits
out of it for sure
um and these prayers we have five
minimum obligatory prayers per day
there's optional ones like Doha and then
which is a night prayer but don't need
to think about that right now the five
daily prayers are the basics no
in Islam right understand that
because you're a revert you have a clean
slate all of your sins are forgiven
inshallah and now we need to start from
the basics so first I would say learning
how to pray is going to be important so
we can send you some videos that we send
the reverts to basically go over how to
pray what the movements are so you get
comfortable with that right then you
know you can do it step by step guided I
just recommend memorizing Surah Fatiha
which is the first chapter of the Quran
it's not that difficult to memorize at
all
um if you recite it even it's it's like
30 30 seconds bro it's not like a long
thing or anything
um so you could play that on repeat for
like a day or two I've known people that
memorized it that quick it's not
anything difficult understand the
meaning too and then basically I would
recommend you to just start praying one
prayer a day right I'm not going to tell
you go into it start five out of five
burn out it's better that you slowly
build this up and not burn out then try
to be on ten toes down right away a few
months and then burn burn out you know
what I mean yeah yeah start with one a
day
um there's different times of them you
can download a Prayer app just with
prayer times or Salat times the first
prayer is fudger right so this is going
to be
um around Don so don is give or take an
hour or two before Sunrise depending on
where you are
um and that's the hours that it's valid
so basically you cannot pray Fajr until
Fajr time comes which is done
um and then it's it's basically you're
done the the time to make that Prayer by
Sunrise so it doesn't mean you can't
make it up after Sunrise if you have a
valid excuse so you forgot or you know
you just overslept you had the intention
of getting up that's fine
um but we should pray on time and we can
talk about that in uh DMS then you have
tohar and Asar which are like during the
day
um you have Maghrib which is right at
Sunset so Maghrib as long as you know
when Sunset is that's as long as it's
valid and then Isha when it comes to the
prayers too
Allah has given this for us bro so I
know a lot of people are like oh why why
are muslims praying all the time you
know like why do you guys need to do
this why does your God need this God
doesn't need this bro we need Salah you
know what I mean yeah and Allah has so
much Mercy on us that he didn't even
make Salah obligatory
um the normal way for people that are
traveling or are ill and stuff like that
so for example if you're traveling
um I believe Scholars can have a
consensus that the distance is about 80
kilometers or so so pretty much leaving
your house going more than 80 kilometers
um if you're traveling overseas you are
basically in the state of being a
traveler so in that state you don't even
have to pray all of the prayers into
entirety so some of them have basically
four Cycles they change the two cycles
they're shortened you can also combine
them literally it's a mercy but it's
made very easy on us and you're a new
revert so I don't expect you to you know
get to that point that you want to get
overnight it's not realistic it's not
feasible but it's very important we
start with the first steps so inshallah
we'll touch base with you in Instagram
and just cover a little bit about how to
pray
yeah I really appreciate that okay of
course bro what's next
um well I suppose I mean I have already
been praying I usually pray as soon as I
wake up and before I go to bed I don't
really know how to pray though you know
it's it's kind of
I don't know I don't know I would
describe it I do it but I don't know how
to do it properly would it be in Arabic
would I have to pray in Arabic oh would
it be okay in English
yeah so the the prayers are in Arabic
and this is something that you have to
learn but again it's like fire said you
don't have to rush you know there is no
rush here Allah knows what's in your
heart and as long as you're making the
intention and making the action not just
the intention but the action and you're
doing little by little little by little
to get to that point
Allah is rewarding you and accepting it
from you the same way
you know it's like it's it doesn't make
sense for you to rush and then burn out
and then not pray at all you know of
course yeah yeah and that's what I said
I just wanted to say my experience
um I I reuterize it because I already
said it earlier in this video
um but for myself man I would literally
put my phone up like this
and I would put a video of this guy
praying
and I'll just follow along bro I had no
idea what to do or what to say but after
doing that several times I started
getting the feel for like the Motions
the movements and then I started
learning the actual Arabic and um
if I were to convince the time frame
because for me like I was all over the
place but if I would have condensed the
time frame I think in less than a week I
was able to do the uh the touraka just
basically the prayer the normal prayer
at least the Fajr and well knowing all
the prayers because it's all doing the
Surah Fatiha and then you can add the
Sunnah prayers after
I just want to clarify one thing bro
um someone said wait isn't optional I
never said I said
d-u-h-a uh it's the one in between Fajr
and foreign
yeah Ethan bro what else what else is on
your mind
well
um
I suppose since I've already started
prayer I can just implement the Islamic
prayer into the prayer I've already been
doing right that's that would be fine
yeah
um
things like a prayer that you're doing
my best for cutting you off I want you
to continue but I have a feeling that
the prayer you're doing now is is a form
of Dua where you're like you're asking a
love for something maybe it's for
um Peace maybe it's for understanding
maybe it's for guidance or something
like this am I correct yeah guidance
always
okay I'm doing that but continue to
continue
um I lost my train of thought
um no no worries bro I was just gonna
add to that too that in Islam
um the default for basically Halal and
Haram meaning like things that we should
abstain from and things that we are
permissible in partaking in
um these things as a generality in
principle
um or everything is halal or permissible
unless explicitly mentioned that it's
Haram so when it comes to most Affairs
in life you can do them unless obviously
there's Revelation or Hadith attending
Hadith or an eye on the Quran basically
making it clear that it's not
permissible you know what I mean but
then when it comes to ibada or acts of
worship here it's the opposite so here
everything's impermissible unless it's
specifically mentioned to be permissible
so someone can't I heard this this one
guy being like Oh I play the musical
some musical instrument for God it's
like okay you know what I mean like sure
I'm sure they have the right intention
but it's not paired with the right
action so because in Islam we have to
adhere to exactly what God wants from us
in terms of the acts of worship
um I would just recommend to learn
um take your time you know and we're
here for you every step of the way
inshallah but take your time to learn
how to pray Salah and then in Salah
itself you can actually make these Dua
when you're prostrating with your head
on the on the floor you can actually
make these Duos that you're making
anyway when you pray you can ask for
protection guidance peace wealth
anything you want if you're going
through a struggle trials and
tribulations you can cry out to Allah
and I think it'll it'll be a little bit
more befitting as a Muslim what do you
think
yeah
you can make Dua at any point too yeah
yeah don't think that you you can only
make them during like the prayer times
like yeah it's separate to the prayer
right
you can combine it you can do it like
like fayetteson you know if you're
making the prostration after you say
what has to be said then you can make
Dua in that prostration
but again if you wake up at like three
a.m in the morning and you can make Dua
it's not like you have to prepare
yourself to make the world now you can
make the world bro it's it's only after
or before the the main prayers and
before the Sunnah prayers as well that
we perform we'll do we'll do is the the
cleansing that we do before going into
the praise the actual
um I'd say the the ritualistic prayers
right I understand I've got here yeah
yeah
um so my next question would be
obviously I'm someone who's sinned a lot
in my life
I'm sure I'll sin again
what how do we cope with that when you
do things that you know are wrong
um beautiful bro so
it's known through Islam that if
mankind did not sin right with the
children of Adam peace be upon him did
not sin then Allah would destroy us
literally destroy us bro and replace us
with a people or civilization that does
sin just so we can repent and understand
the value of Allah's Mercy what does
this mean
it basically means that Allah
understands that every son and I believe
the prophet saws mentioned this in
Hadith too that every son of Adam is a
sinner like every like there's no
exception bro
um the best of Sinners are those that
repent you know what I mean so
understanding that sinning by nature is
nothing weird or bad or something you
should be nihilistic about understanding
obviously ignorance and arrogance are
two different things so if you're
ignorant and you don't know it's a
lifelong journey bro the thing with
Islam is
it's it's very multifaceted you're not
going to understand everything that our
sins and things we should avoid
overnight bro I'm like a couple years
into practicing Islam myself and I'm
just like I still have moments where I
am finding out new things you know what
I mean I'm sure that's the same with
Arnold too so it's it's a lifelong thing
treated as that
um but understand you're gonna sin when
you do sin the best thing that you could
do is repent uh sincerely to Allah and
actually make Dua to Allah to help you
overcome these things you know I know
today we're a little bit too Dunya or
materialistic related in our Affairs we
think that okay if I have a medical
condition then I need a medication if I
have this mental problem I need therapy
if I'm financially struggling I just
need to go out and make more money so I
get it bro it's the input output X and Y
but when it comes to our Affairs as
Muslims we should always rely on Allah
first and foremost is something huge
because many people don't right so I
know you might be like okay if you're
struggling with let's say nofap or
you're struggling with some addiction
right I know you might want to go watch
YouTube videos and other advice and I'm
sure there's practical advice I'm not
denying that but relying first and
foremost on Allah is pivotal bro to make
it easy for you making Allah I'm
struggling with this I want to leave
this for your sake please help me
overcome this please help me abstain
from this and you'll immensely notice
this like spiritual boost and you're
just being basically protected by Allah
from these things
um yeah I've already experienced that to
be honest like I said and I dealt with
addiction from like the ages of
12 till last year when I'm 22 now so you
know that's like drugs and [__]
um
sorry man language but
yeah it was obviously a a very a very
difficult thing to deal with addiction
and the only thing that ever did help
was prayer so yeah that makes sense
that's amazing bro I know what do you
say about sins
well look the beautiful thing is that
when you become Muslim all your sins are
wiped away alhamdulillah
but that's not to say that we're going
to be sending this you know like
and
just know that the I'd say the first
multiple times that you've seen
after this point from you or not and
again like I don't I don't want you to
sing I'm not trying to like
uh
foreshadow or something like bad things
happening to you no I'm not the strong
moon but all I'm saying is that
inevitably like as humans we are going
to sin and I'm telling you about like as
a reverb when you do sin after you've
like been wiped away from all your sins
oh it hurts man
it hurts and like you you'll be in
prayer you'll be in like prostration
and you'll just be crying because it's
like it's just like it it's real man
it's not fake at all it's real
and all I can say is that uh this is
Hadith where the Prophet Muhammad
he he said that
when one sins uh it's like this black
dot goes on your heart
and the more you sin the more these
black dots begin to increase until your
heart is covered in this Veil this like
Black Veil and at that point once it
gets to that point you no longer know
what's good from what's bad
at that point you'll do something that's
bad and you'll think it's good for you
or you'll do something that's good for
you and you think it's bad and then you
don't want to do it at all so when it
comes to that point it's like
well actually you don't want to you
don't actually let it come to that point
you know you always want to be making
repentance and asking for forgiveness
for Allah but just know that
um if you ever do start getting to this
point like Allah is the most merciful
Allah is the one that's like it's
literally it's his two of his names
it's like the most merciful and the most
the especially merciful
and there's another one there especially
most for any especially
um
that means the most merciful means
especially merciful uh I see yeah see
yeah is it I believe so let me let me
Google that while you look it up I don't
think that's what it is I got you bro
means the most beneficent
um or the most merciful and then other
Rahim
means
yeah especially merciful or continuous
merciful yes but but look how beautiful
that is bro that like
I'll bro Allah knows what's you know
Allah knows that we're gonna sin Allah
knows everything because he's already
written it bro he's already written it
and it's not because he intends bad for
us when we do these things but it's
because he intends the best for us he
wants us to learn he wants us to grow
and we as humans we don't grow unless we
suffer unless we struggle through
adversity
so we have to go through these things
and Allah always the all of that are all
Allah asks us to do well it tells a
situation he tells us just come back to
him trust in him that's it you don't
have to do anything like if you're over
here crying and you're suffering because
you're addicted to something or or
you're having these issues like bro like
go to Allah Allah is the one that's
gonna heal you Allah is the one that's
going to take care of everything for you
you don't have money Allah is the one
that's going to provide for you you
don't have food to eat Allah is the one
that's going to provide for you
you're sick Bro the doctor could give
you a medicine but if if Allah doesn't
will for this medicine to cure you the
medicine's not going to do anything so
again it's it's all goes back to Allah
so as long as you keep going back to
Allah no matter what you do
you know what can you do like just keep
asking for forgiveness keep going back
to Allah and
remember that Allah is the most merciful
for me especially move I love that bro
may Allah bless you for that and Ethan
bro I hope that that kind of resonated a
little bit hit something in your heart
um because it definitely resonated with
me
um so someone writes or asks what
happens if your heart is completely
blocked like Donald said um if you
didn't make it clear already like Allah
does basically make it very known in the
Quran which is the second chapter of the
Quran that basically those that have
healed hearts or their hearts are sealed
at that point like that's it bro there's
not much you could do but but Allah also
mentions in the same Surah in Surah
al-baqarah that never will anyone be
misguided or basically not get the
guidance from Allah unless those that
are defiantly disobedient and arrogant
meaning the people that they just don't
even want to be safe bro they don't even
want to open their mind up to the truth
so if you generally want to pray for
guidance like brother Ethan has been
doing you will inshallah get get hit on
we gotta we gotta trust in that yeah and
then sister can you please talk about
Free Will and Destiny I'm so confused so
in Islam there's one disclaimer that I
want to give very clearly to everyone
listening and tuning in that there's
many things that are areas of confusion
or doubt sometimes we are unclear on
these things right and I want to make a
known that the answers to all these
questions are are all out there they've
all been answered you can find them
online it's very simple so anytime you
do come across something where it's like
a doubt or you're like oh how does this
make sense or how do I basically
rationalize this understand you can come
to us DM us at the three Muslims on IG
or do some research online now
pertaining to this
I'm sure a lot of you maybe brother
Ethan maybe brother Angel I know at
least myself I came across this doubt um
or confusion when I was you know very
new into practicing Islam that what is
this whole thing about Free Will and
Destiny because if if God gave us free
will right and we we are in control of
if we sin or not sin but then God also
broke down what we're gonna do how are
we accountable then didn't God because
do these things and no because God
didn't make us do these things see the
Divine decree or the color of Allah that
was basically written in everything that
everyone's going to do every decision
someone's gonna make right
they weren't things that Allah made us
do Allah just wrote down before we were
even here what we're gonna do
so in a sense it's basically writing
down what the decree is what everyone's
going to do all the sins they're going
to commit it's not that Allah made like
a program or anything and then clicked
execute and then we just did all these
things no we still have free will Allah
wrote down everything that we did with
our own free will
Allah also wrote down everything and in
the other things that we didn't do and
what would have happened had we done
those things but we didn't so the Divine
decree is very multifaceted but it's not
something that God made us do so I want
everyone to understand that it just it's
basically writing down everything that
we will do
um but we still did it in the sense so
we can't blame like oh God wrote this so
I'm gonna do it no God wrote it but you
still did it if that makes sense
you know you know the whole free world
and Destiny team that's something I
never was really confused about hunting
there just because I've always played
video games when I was younger
the example that I want to give is like
you have a video game which is created
by a developer
right this video game has many many
different ways that the the game can end
but the Creator the developer of this
video game knows exactly all the ways
that it can help
right
now when you as the gamer plays this
game
you have the free will to choose
whatever you want in this game and what
you choose will depict what the end of
the game is going to be what the outcome
of the game is going to be how the
experience is going to be but the one
who created the video game already knows
exactly what it is that you're going to
experience
yeah and then when this happened it's
like
that's it's a lot like life man like
Allah has created everything Allah has
already written it all and we are here
just making decisions if you if you
really think about your life
all it is is just the decisions that you
make because the decisions you make
results in an action and the action
results in a reaction but it's all
decisions bro this entire life is all
decisions and these decisions is what
free will is and the Free Will is what
begins to unravel what your life is
right now and what it's going to be and
how it's going to end and where you're
going to end up at the end
um I do want to add to that beautiful
point that we're not comparing a lot to
video game developers it's just an
analogy and we must understand that
video game developers are made from
human beings that are limited and they
basically code them in a way where
there's there's kind of like an
algorithm or like an order of events
that could happen whereas the god of
Allah Allah still did the same thing but
Allah also wrote down what we actually
end up doing where the video game it's
kind of like open source like you could
go this way or that way Allah also gave
us the option but knows which one we
were going to do we still made that
decision once again to go this way or
that way so Allah didn't make us do it
in a way
um but just wanted to clear that up
100.
Ethan bro anything else and don't feel
like you have to create questions that
you don't even have uh just because I
keep asking you I just want to make sure
that you leave this with a little bit of
security and certainty
um in some of the things that might be a
little bit unclear if there any
yeah so
I mean I don't really know many Muslims
in person the ones I I used to know were
I wouldn't say though they were the best
Muslims or like drug dealers and and
stuff
um
I suppose how do I go about
networking we got through other Muslims
where are you from where do you live
England a city called hope in England
okay dmida on IG I'm gonna put out a
community post on on T3 on Instagram and
I'll find some beautiful Brothers for
you to be connected to number one
inshallah number two you can go to the
Masjid and for the mosques and
just organically find the community but
I think doing it this way it'll take a
little bit of the pressure away
um and understand it's it's one of those
things like I want to give a huge shout
out to brother Anthony and West if you
are watching this bro uh he did a
shahada
um and then he got on the stream with us
I think months ago but even a year ago
and he is a rebirth as well from America
and right now he has an amazing
Community he's always posting stuff on
IG
um because I follow him and he's he's
posting you know going to these events
these Retreats and he has a huge
community of Muslims when he reverted he
didn't really know anyone so it's very
normal to kind of like it's like
if you ever go to college out of state
you know day one you don't know anyone
there you you're coming from high school
you're coming from your old Clique you
come into college you don't know anyone
here you don't know where anything is
it's all new right but then look at
someone in like fourth year or their
final year of college they're not going
to be lonely they're going to know
everyone so understand it's just
something that comes with time I think
on Health phone definitely died so
inshallah he can make it back before we
wrap it up but I just want to make it
make it clear that it's there's no
pressure and it's just something we just
got to take step by step but I will do
my best to facilitate that um when you
DM me the city see if there's anyone
there there's going to be a lot of
people inshallah yeah okay great yeah I
think that's all to be honest I'm the
love bro so if you have no other
questions I think inshallah we'll just
touch base in Instagram uh the group
chat that I make and in the meantime uh
just make some Dua to Allah to continue
keeping you steadfast in the right path
to keep you out of Harm's Way and
everyone in the comments or in the war
chat please make the welcome brother
Ethan
um that he stays on the right path and
more and more people can be influenced
by him though so the prophet saws
um this is something unique to Islam you
know in other religions sure they were
given Messengers and Prophets right but
when you look at Islam the prophet peace
be upon him not only gave us Revelation
but in his final sermon and in many of
the professional thoughts he basically
told us that dawa or spreading Islam
spreading the truth is something we must
take on a personal level too it doesn't
just end with him his resolution peace
be upon him it's something that we
should all do so that's why right now
um understand
you know the prophet saws mentioned
convey from me even if it's one verse
literally one verse like one line of the
Quran so it just goes to show that you
won't have to become a scholar number
one you don't need to go to Street Dao
or none of this bro but first and
foremost
you're a clock leading by example and
being in good character that's first and
foremost bro and and this could be
something like for example let's say
some of us have foul speech or we grew
up in the west people are swearing
cussing rap music whatever right all of
a sudden you become Muslim and let's say
you understand Allah doesn't really like
foul speech it's not befitting we
represent Islam let's say you make these
changes and you stop swearing right this
alone is you're not telling anyone about
the Quran you're not telling anyone
about anything but they know you're
Muslim now
you're a little bit more empathetic you
know what I mean so that what doesn't
necessarily have to be active direct
dawa
um talking about Islam preaching it
could also be indirect and that's like
the first and foremost the bare minimum
um but I just wanted to leave you with
that because I understand that
um now people will use you as an example
and a lot of people that might be on the
fence maybe even someone brother living
in England though maybe close to you
watching this video they're like oh I've
been Christian I've been thinking of
Islam I don't know what to do oh brother
Ethan did it and that inspired him maybe
let's say to take the shadow tonight in
his bedroom so you gotta understand that
now we are a force of good and we have
to continue making Dua to Allah to keep
us that force of good and allow us to
inspire more people and inshallah will
accept it from us
I think with that being said bro
um inshallah we will touch base and to
everyone watching in stay tuned for uh
this Wednesday we will stream and then
Saturday in a week from now we're going
to bring on Sunny fast and his mom for
part two inshallah smash the like button
down below and with that being said
salaam alaikum